hello there i'm gav a portion of this
video is sponsored by free trade you may
remember a few years ago we spun a
record so fast that it decided it didn't
want to be a record anymore and while i
was editing it i thought it'd be a good
idea if i spun the footage around at the
same speed that the record was spinning
so that from our perspective it was
stationary and you could see all the
warping and wibbling as it was under the
pressure of the spin and i thought
spinning the footage of something that
is spinning is an interesting enough
concept in itself to warrant its own
video so today i'm going to be doing it
with paint and spinning the paint on
these wooden discs the 4k phantom is
mounted above looking straight down at
the spinning disc which in an absolute
slow-mo guys bodge job is sat in a
paddling pool balanced on some chairs
just so i don't spray paint all over the
room and all over the uh expensive
computer equipment and i'm going to
crawl underneath here attach a drill to
this bolt sticking through and then
blast it at full speed and that should
spin the disc very suddenly flinging
paint all over the place okay let's try
some random dollops here and there
bit cramped under here okay here we go
three two one
oh my god that's not bad you know
i'm quite a fan of that the way this is
attached to this drill bit this is like
a sanding drill bit so when i
let off the drill
all of the momentum then undoes the
little nut the screw so it's also
self-removing
okay so immediately i'm noticing there's
too much motion blur which means i need
to decrease the exposure time of each
frame introducing a much higher shutter
speed that will hopefully sharpen up a
lot of the motion blur and i tell you
what we could probably do with a higher
frame rate too i might switch this up to
2000 and uh go to hd on this one
okie dokie attempt number two i'm just
going to try something a little
different i'm just going to stack the
color in the middle so we get a layered
effect
this one's gonna be harder to get the
screw off
let's see what happens
that's pretty cool lost a lot of the
middle colors they sort of just sloughed
off
it's actually so convenient that it
just automatically detaches it's very
interesting how the uh different
consistencies of paint have sort of like
a hydrophobic effect i quite like that
one you know okay playing back
well that's the nicest speed isn't it
much more leisurely just
the way it just enlarges
wow
i'm a fan of that there's actually
little lumps in there in the paint in
the yellow there and it's as they spread
out they're carving little channels so
you can see the blue underneath that's
interesting that was a much shorter
shutter duration instead of 500
microseconds that was 84 microseconds
giving us a
shutter angle of 60.
all right we seem to be getting closer
with this the background pretty ugly
though so i'm going to put this white
foam board a little bit nicer than a
scrambled blue paddling pool
[Applause]
oh yeah you can see here the
nice marbling effect but you get so many
different variants of the colors
that fiery mixture towards the edges
just looks really cool
without the white it's a much harsher
blend between the colors
such a crazy perspective
this is as if your head could rotate at
thousands of rpm
for this one i'm using acrylic instead
of the tempera paint that i've been
using up to this point and you can see
here the paints are dragging much more
forcefully through each other really
brings out that green between the yellow
and the blue
[Music]
the ones with white on actually give a
much plainer final result but the
in-progress footage is i think much more
interesting all the different colors you
can see towards the edge they eventually
get
covered up or
shut off but it's so interesting in the
footage
i think the final result of this one
looks so cool so i'm going to try and
get this again on a clean background
[Applause]
i love that one
oh it's just so
it's almost hypnotic
you get lost in this
that's one of my favorites
this one is the same but with acrylic
instead of
temper paint
slightly more viscous
which seems to lead to a slightly
tighter spiral effect
okay for this last one i want to include
all the colors but also have that
mixture effect that you get with white
so i'm just going to pour white all over
the middle of this to hopefully get a
much nicer blend of the colors in the
footage
[Applause]
looks like an absolute mess at the
beginning whoa
look at all those colors towards the
edge that is amazing i could definitely
stare at that one for a while
[Music]
i think this would actually make a
really interesting
smartwatch face
smartwatch makers get in touch
email if you want to collab
well that was nice i think we got some
really good looking footage there as
well as a few little souvenirs out of it
so definitely going to do something with
these at some point in the future a lot
of the recent videos have been more on
the informative side so it's nice to go
back to just a plain old artsy one i
haven't done one in a while but they are
very fun to make hopefully you enjoyed
that video make sure you subscribe if
you like slow-mo
bang a like on it if it's deserving of
an extra an extra click and i'll see you
in the next one now i'm going to tell
you about the sponsor of this video free
trade free trade is an investing app
that offers commission free trading so
you get to keep more of your profits and
it also offers u.s fractional stocks
that means if you've got a stock that
buying one of is obscenely expensive you
can buy much smaller portions of that
stock so you're not limited when you
want to invest in some of the bigger
companies as this is a promotion for a
financial institution i do need to give
you the following disclaimer
as with all investments your capital is
at risk the value of your portfolio can
go down as well as up and you may get
back less than you invest however if you
would like to support this channel as
well as free trade go to free trade dot
io slo-mo guys download the app create
and fund your account and you'll get a
random free share worth between three
and two hundred pounds such as greg's
right move
or apple
man it's been a while since i've had a
greg's
i think i'm hungry
oh tuna sandwich excellent thank you
very much for sitting through the ad if
you got this far i'll see you next time
you